I would like first to um to express my
um thanks for and my gratitude to be
able to participate in this very
important conference that uh relate to
the future of our
civilization and for the opportunity
which is given to me to express my
opinion on this problem I have called
diit the special type of relationships
that Muslim have establ L with
non-muslims in the religious political
and social domains this relationships
are based on the Quran and the Sunnah
there are mandatory and regulated by the
Sharia they implement the Islamic
conception of the world what I call diud
is called by Muslims tolerance but I
prefer the a a concept which
express um the judeo Christian and
Western point of view on this
condition uh it is my opinion that with
massive Muslim immigration in Europe and
probably in other Western regions diud
that is the traditional religious and
historical way Muslims relate to
non-muslims have immigrated to the
West uh there are many reason for that
some have been um touched upon by um
distinguished lecture before me first it
is the obfuscation of this
subject the difficulties to discuss
freely on Islamic
matters uh because of fear because of
threat and also because of the
accusation of
islamophobia which um never which is
never
agreeable uh to receive I will just give
a few examples of this diud in the
domain of the perception of history for
instance it is religious history and
profane history I first the religious
history
um is the whole Humanity born Muslim
because this is the way Muslim think of
uh the of the human being in this case
are we
apostate and this here I um join with um
with Robert uh to say that infidels
those who uh refuse to acknowledge that
um there are Muslim they know Islam is
truth but nevertheless they um they
continue in their error represent the
worst of evil so are we uh apostate for
the Muslim who comes here and also for
the billions I think 1 billion and a
half Muslims outside of Europe it is
important that we realize that how they
see
us uh do we have
if we are not apostate Muslim what the
they see as our identity do we have an
identity a religious
identity for instance they deny the the
truth or the the
existence um of the Biblical history for
them for Islam the whole Biblical
history and all the uh figures in the in
the Bible are all Muslims included
including Jesus who is a Muslim Prophet
who preach Islam and uh his name is Issa
so in fact this is the reason of the
Islamic uh isra Israel Islamic um
conflict that the Bible and the reality
and the history of the Bible is not
accepted and that the Muslim says that
nor is Israel nor the Jews nor the
Christians have any root in the land in
the Holy Land because uh before Islam
the popul before J Judaism and
Christianity and before the Bible the
population was
Muslims so uh our even our um our
religious identity is therefore uh
denied uh the denial of the Bible
including the
gospel uh deny the Jewish and Christian
identity and uh we can ask ask ourself
is Christianity rooted in the Muslim
Jesus in
Isa um in this case judeo Christianity
does not exist as it has been said said
several time but by several um
politicians and theologians it doesn't
exist it is a fake because the history
of Judaism and the Bible is a fake and
of of course Al also the gospel and
Christianity belongs to Islam through
Isa and it has to come back to Islam to
its roots and we see that this extreme
militancy Islamic is
militancy which is working on the uh the
the churches the Oriental churches which
are like hostages in the Islamic country
so I would say that if uh Europe has uh
renounce to recognize its
judeo-christian identity it is because
it thought that turkey will come in and
turkey refus that identity and also it
is in know to accommodate the Muslim
immigrant because they refuse the judeo
Christian identity of Europe and they
will never integrate in such a such a
Europe now about profane history is
Jihad a genocidal War this is according
to our own criteria Western criteria or
it is just a sacred Duty performed to
suppress infidelity According to Islamic
criteria so the alliance of civilization
and the analin foundation and and
European governments have chosen the
Islamic version we should not discuss
nor criticize Jihad and I think this was
said also that we cannot use certain
words Jihad enters in the Lexicon of
forbidden words because they offend
Muslim sens abilities so we have to
accept What Muslim consider um a just
war and which is according to our
criteria it is a war of anation and
destruction against us and we have to
say that this is a just war and we are
forbidden to um to criticize it now is
Islamic religious slavery a taboo
subject we know that we are we discuss
and this is very good we submit to um to
historical um criticism racism uh racist
uh
enslavement but why not doing the same
with religious enslavement which is
inscribed into the laws of jihad which
has been performed in since the
beginning of Islam and is Contin until
now in Africa and which has a much more
bigger ex geographical extension and
temporal extension in history so why
can't we speak about that it is another
taboo subject and what about imperialism
and Conquest we can Muslim imperialism
because we cannot speak about Muslim
imperialism or Conquest because Muslim
believe that when there are conquering
lands when they're taking lands they
take lands that belongs to them because
they have been promised to them by Allah
and what they do when they perform Jihad
it is to go and take back their own land
that the infidels keeps illegally so
what they're doing is a defensive War to
um to have their own right on this land
and when the the infidel fight them it
is them who are aggressive it is always
the infidels who are aggressive and the
Muslim are fighting a um uh self-defense
War so now we cannot discuss about this
problem and um and we have to accept we
have to accept the Islamic Vision on
their Conquest we don't discuss about
Islamic imperialism and now about
relativism has Europe a
civilization according according to the
OIC this is the organization of the
Islamic conference which bring together
56 country um and according to the
analin
foundation uh Europe with and the West
with the Muslim World form one single
civilization with a diversity of kind
we cannot speak about different
civilization because this imply a clash
of civilization so we are together in
one
civilization but now the OIC requests
that Europe recognize the immense
contribution of Islamic culture and
civilization to Europe's development and
that it includes this subject in school
and University syllabus so in fact our
Western Civilization is an Islamic
civilization we don't we don't have a
religious identity we don't have history
and we don't have even an an
Civilization by our own now what about
the perceptions of right of Europeans in
relation to Muslim immigrants we are
constantly reminded by the OIC and
particularly at its 2005 Mega Symposium
that we have to feel guilty guilty
because of the Crusade guilty because um
of because of um imperialism of
colonialism and this biggest biggest sin
of all time the restoration of the state
of Israel
and this is exactly what they say in
this the recommendations in
international relations done by this uh
distinguished um OIC Summit address the
moral obligation of Western Powers which
directly or indirectly contributed to
the Injustice oppression aggression and
long-standing disputes involving Muslim
peoples and assist in uh in raising the
socioeconomic standards of the poor
countries in the South the south is the
Islamic South so because we are guilty
toward the Muslims we must pay for the
cultural and economic development and
this of course cost billions and
billions of e EU uh Eros and without any
control now this is a moral and fiscal
Duty that demies have to perform so in
Europe we must provide also the
immigrants this is the request from the
OIC we have to provide them with
adequate lodging education schooling
Health Services good salaries and show
difference to them and this was also
addressed by a speaker we have to
uh therefore we we must uh we cannot use
certain words these are the Lexicon of
forbidden words and we have to train
civil servants and doctors and teachers
who are in contact with uh Muslim
immigrant in order to teach them not to
offend Muslim
sensibilities and what about
multiculturalism we are told that we
must accept
multiculturalism even though we do not
want it because European National
identities and values are all
islamophobic our government should
suppress this is values our identities
from
Europe but what is
islamophobia according to um the
OIC and it report on the it second
report on islamophobia
2009 um European National identities
anti-terrorist measures and the refusal
to accept illegal immigration are a
racist xenophobic and islamophobic
obstruction to
multiculturalism because immigration
ought to continue IND
definitely not withstanding native
opposition European restrictions on
immigration are
islamophobic Muslim suffers from dis
discrimination and this has been said SE
several time at the
um at the Council of Human right Muslims
suffer discrimination in Europe because
of two major problems Europe security
imperative and European National
identities but but what the OIC demand
from us and what is their uh their
request to the EU and to the European
commissions the Islamic presence says
the the OIC is irreversible and
definitive and Europe must restructure
itself into a
multiethnic and Multicultural Society
the OIC declared in several of its
statements that Muslim immigrants in the
west are part of the universal um and
this is in its um Charter of
2008 and because it is part of this
European immigrants Muslim immigrants
they are part of the universal um it is
the duty of the OIC to protect them and
Safeguard the religious and cultural
heritage of their home countries Muslim
home countries in their host countries
so they have the right to protect to
keep and the duty to keep their National
their religious and National and
historical uh identities in Europe and
the OIC has to protect that from any any
form of discrimination oppression and
exclusion Muslims say the OIC have a
shared identity that would be for in the
west particularly in Europe through the
mandatory knowledge of Arabic the
language of Revelation and the Islamic
faith and through the learning of
Islamic history and
civilization this will be provided this
learning this teaching will be provided
by the coordination throughout Europe
and uh the Western World of a vast
network of Islamic teachers schools
institutes and
universities that would spread this
teaching Islamic teaching from the
cradle
accompanying men and women in Youth and
adulthood throughout their working lives
providing the necessary support by
planning and
educational cultural and social program
and this is done by uh the Esco one of
the main body of the OIC now it is being
done and of course our European
governments have accepted all that now
teaching immigrant Muslim children the
greatness of their Heritage would allow
them to realize the fullness of the
borrowing from Islam in every aspect of
Western Civilization that means that we
don't have a civilization every aspect
of Western Civilization is in fact
Islamic
Islamic identity would govern and
organize every facet of Life Of The
Immigrant and would Define both behavior
and interpersonal
relationships this is a quotation such
planning ought to strengthen the
presence of Islam in the west activating
the role of Islamic culture and
safeguarding and immunizing Islamic
identity against European
influence as a conclusion I would say
that Europe is considered to be a vast
area for
colonization a continent in which
nationalism and Native cultures and
identities should be
eliminated as were those of the non of
non-muslim inhabitants of land islamized
after the jihadist
conquest because this is the view of the
Muslim world and we are not going
against it we are not fighting against
it our EU
apparatus in the contrary through
several transnational and
international um uh networks and
lobbyists are working and collaborating
with the
OIC now Europe are obliged to leave as
in war time to submit to searches on
public transport and in public places
while the OIC multiplied the number of
International Conference and dialogues
including at the UN complaining of
Europeans islamophobia from which Muslim
immigrants suffer while they continue to
flow into Europe from their own wind
like demons westerners are obliged to
accept the demographic and cultural
colonization of their own
territory they have to renounce their
National History identity and culture as
well as the right to defend themselves
because this is islamophobia anti
measure anti-terrorist measure are
islamophobic so we are in a
culture and in a political system of
diud without knowing it and we can ask
ourselves if all these numerous
dialogues and
um and
lobbies and
um um Alliance of civilization andalin
foundation and so on are not in fact um
a conduct for da this is
predication and if it is not also a way
for the OIC to impact and to bring its
own views uh within the uh European uh
system in fact we have internalized the
Islamic view on us through this n
International
networks uh and and to which in fact are
ruling us because as it has been so well
explain the European have lost the
control of their own democracy their own
system this is done through OPAC uh
networks
faceless which take uh decisions that no
one
controls like for instance the Eur
Parliament which is one of this uh this
uh networks and which impact on our
policy without us knowing it on matter
of Education
syllabus uh on everything on immigration
and in making us feel that we are guilty
and we have to pay and that we are
racist and xenophobic as many of my
friends here know it because there are
the victims of this
accusations thank
you thank you very the um comments you
made on European guilt and the
expectation of European guilt reminded
me of a of a new book just came out in
English by Pascal Brookner the tyranny
of guilt which if any of you haven't
haven't got I'd very much recommend
which describes very nicely as you did
the way in which all Western born
non-muslims are responsible for
everything that was ever done by any
Western born non-muslims and yet no
muslim is ever responsible even for
their own actions and if anyone has any
doubt about that um the existence of
that rather neat Tire uh the Guardian
newspaper just two days ago ran an
article on the uh suspected Times Square
car bomber uh with what I thought was
that even for the guardian pretty good
headline which said a um Time Square
suspect suffered mortgage
forclosure which I'm sure you'd agree
with me would suggest that America is
right for hundreds of thousands of car
bombings in in the current Uh current
climate and that actually this isn't a
problem of jihadists trained in Pakistan
but a a fanny and Freddy problem um
at least they know where to abortion
blame anyhow um I'm sorry to abuse the
chair but I'd like to invite uh Paul
Marshall